well flashpoint beyond picks up shortly
after flashpoint ended thomas wayne
wakes up back in the flashpoint world
not understanding exactly what's
happened why is everything back to what
he knows as his life and the mystery is
what the hell's happening while we're
following thomas wayne's story in the
flashpoint universe
we also are going to be following bruce
wayne in our universe and then meeting
jeremy and tim i've been fans of both
their work at dc already
and they're great people and great
brains and they come at things very
differently and so we all jammed
together like everybody else
you know that world of possibilities
that flashpoint represented is something
that i've always
thought about that's what you want when
you come to the flashpoint universe you
want to see characters that you're semi
familiar with but the little surprises
that change it but it really came to
before everyone signed on i think was
like
why do it like why are we going back to
flashpoint this very personal emotional
story has much bigger ramifications on
the dc universe people would look at
flashpoint beyond and think oh this is a
you know this will be a fun little
contained story i think those people
probably have another thing coming we
knew that there was this giant conflict
between the amazonians and the
atlanteans that we will kind of see
where that ended up when superman comes
in but there's a whole new layer to
superman's story it gives even more
twists
on
who the man of tomorrow is in this
universe but also different takes on
villains from the scavenger who's a bit
of an obscure aquaman villain to the
rogues they're all they're all in here
every time cervantes turns in a new page
it's like oh we're all like oh my god
this is our favorite page so far there
are small
detailed
beautiful character moments that
zermatto is putting on the page this is
the work of his career i think people
are going to be blown away by his work
flashpoint beyond does bring back some
characters and play with some characters
that haven't been at the forefront of
the dc universe in a while and you will
see plans with them going forward
you